[Music]  Republican senators Joni Ernst and my  clear and veiling a new proposal for  paid family leave the cradle Act would  allow new parents to use their social  security savings to pay for time off  after the birth or adoption of a child  users would then delay their retirement  to pay the money back I think most  people would look at this as an  opportunity that they might not  otherwise have an opportunity to benefit  from payments that they've been making  already for years why is the u.s. so far  behind the rest of the industrialized  world on this issue I think that is a  really great question and that's why we  have decided now is the time to step up  and really do something about this we  think it's time to catch up with other  countries and we'll home more about  their proposal tomorrow only on CBS this  morning